Danny why crawling around in the dark
were you actually asleep of course not I
was trying to save on light bulbs
haven't slept for about two months I
wanna consult now
I'm acupuncture none of it works are you
still up how was your day
oh I saw this ad for some new pills
called snoozes no they don't knock you
out they just make everything taste like
cabbage apart from cabbage
little I could put a saddle on it and
ride it into town
sorry it's my bedtime
hey there you are remember that dating
app that you sent me up for I got a
match that's great I kept calling you
all night Lisa we're just mates not from
where I'm standing
okay
when I'm sleeping there's this whole
world of leases that I know nothing
about hello I'm not sailing what what
there's a big bunch of cows cows attack
let me check
yeah yeah they do attack and they do and
they kill what
I don't think you know what it's like
for your partner to come alive as soon
as you go to bed
[Music]
I don't know what I want to do we're all
trying our best all it takes is that one
person to really see you
tonight's the big night first date I've
got with a few ideas to help her feel
more at ease why don't you just put a
padlock on your fly I think that will
really power ease because it what do you
mean no
[Music]